madam race or the aullène area for
the european commission dear christine
schaer charles
thank you very much for the invitation it is
very nice not to receive you here from
coubertin at 9:06 a.m.
we are from guardians of it is very
special yes yes out of
lisbon audience question and 18 seconds on
the trio philippe alfonsi fabrice madouas
pardus aux responsibilities too many
responsibilities to leave you knew that
is strong bad the way we are and height
of spirit very pretty girl thing if
our part and things continue to  a
chip wi drive liberties single mark of
8-1 previous titles economic
opportunities and release of duty to
appraiser major topics buzzman
very nice gesture urban raid promises urban
fioutch you be something that you have
to be hot brick by brick and day by day
thenergo  took the elevator in disguise
millions of people have taken the
streets weaving two days pink
floyd landis period
mrs james
[applause]
mrs chri  stine lagarde president of the
european central bank
hello everyone bad side
giorno a gbagbo meeting and i
should speak french four
presidents together two men two
women
we are present in the museum
of european history
our african friends often say  if you
don't know where you're going ask yourself where you're from
you give wiring as who
offers you came from you will find a
way of kings over the last
decades europe to overcome so many
difficulties but me as president  from
the european central bank I also look at
the last ten years that have
been said